so there's a very narrow range of things
that you're allowed to pay attention to
or care about or be mad about as you
know a couple weeks ago months ago it
was corona before that was white
supremacy now it's ukraine
but as you're totally absorbed in
whatever that one big story is all kinds
of other things are going on and here's
one of them the bite administration is
flying huge numbers of illegal aliens
who snuck into our country mostly
through texas up to the northeast in
this case to westchester new york now
they haven't announced that they're
doing this
because i guess in a democracy you can
do whatever you want it doesn't matter
what people think we only know about it
because a former westchester county
executive called rob astorino noticed he
obtained the footage you're now seeing
on your screen
so buses at your expense are
transporting illegal foreign nationals
right as they land but it's not clear
where they're going the bite
administration won't tell us because
again it's not our country it's theirs
rob astorino is now using the democratic
process to restore power to people he's
running for governor of the state of new
york we're happy to have him joining us
tonight rob astrino thanks so much for
coming on so this is continuing
um have you been able to get any answers
from the administration over what
they're doing
none whatsoever i asked in august 13th
when i blew the lid on this had a press
conference wanted to know who was coming
in were they vaccinated we had public
health issues public safety issues
public's right to know and dead silence
other than calling me and everybody who
questioned them a racist and a hater and
then the new york post did a great job
blowing it up and then the flight
stopped for a while
still no answers though now the flights
have resumed one came in sunday night
that you have the video of of them
deplaning and
the buses and one just came in one hour
ago taco to westches uh tucker to
westchester county airport and they're
deplaning right now so this is gonna
continue and the biden administration
must have such contempt for americans
that they're importing people from other
countries
flying them into the interior and just
dispersing them and then turning them
into voters like new york city where
they will be allowed to vote with 30-day
residency
and governor kathy hokel she has set up
a two billion dollar fund in new york so
that's a magnet for free stuff for
anyone to come here so they get a phone
then they get the el prasso express uh
to westchester and everywhere else and
then they get on almost all the other
goodies and the entire time we the
citizens will even get an answer from
our government and we get stuck with the
tab
you're an elected governor by the way
kathy hokel has never been elected
governor of the state of new york
speaking of democracy so do citizens of
new york who pay some of the highest tax
rates in the country they get free
phones and free flights free
transportation
no
no you know we get to do we still get to
wear masks on our flights we still get
to have to mask our toddlers
we still get uh you know fingers pointed
at us for being bad people and not
saying it's a good thing that people are
coming across our border what's going to
happen by the way title 42 which is
going to be rescinded that's the last
tool in the toolbox for customs and
border patrol agents to send people back
to expel them once they're no longer
have that by the owen administration's
admission they're going to be flooded
even more so you're going to have more
flights and more bus loads coming into
our schools our communities and they'll
never tell us who it is
it's it's all beyond it's all beyond
belief i hope you're rewarded for your
honesty rob astorino running for
governor new york thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight